yes Fritzi we've got a special guest
calling him who is actor comedian
Michael Rapaport and New York Knick fan
oh boy where are you right now Dan I am
in Portland Oregon I am out here I am
disappointed that I'm not going to be at
the Knicks game tonight I am excited to
be performing at the helium comedy club
in Portland all weekend which I've never
performed at it I've never been out here
in my life but as far as the the Knicks
are concerned if I was in New York
tonight then I would definitely be
asking you to be on high alert because
despite the fact that it's been another
painful
start to a season and and and and and
and I think and you maybe you're an
expert you're some sort of expert you're
you're great sports Mike
maybe you could explain to me what Steve
Mills Hill said is why Steve Mills
through who's what is he now the
president of basketball operations why
Steve Mills through the hiring of every
single coach the derek Fisher's that Dan
and Tony's the Kurt Rambis is the hurt
ones why Steve Mills continues to have a
job you already said he's a salary cap
guy I think that's his expertise yeah
you know what I got a guy at my local
delicatessen he's good at math we could
get him my guy Lenny he does all the
numbers for my delicate he could do that
the salary cap Steve Mills has no
basketball skills and if and when and I
think it's and when more importantly
when the Knicks finally fire Steve Mills
I guarantee you that Steve Mills will
never have another job in the NBA I
don't know what kind of arrangement he
has with with dolan but if you're going
to get rid of fizz dale and you're gonna
get rid of steep a Scott Perry why not
finally get rid of Steve Mills because
obviously his record is is worse than
any any mixed coach that's ever come in
there and and and at a certain point we
need to out like not just sort of clean
house clean house that being said I do
not think they should even be in the
discussion
a firing Davis Tisdale I I expect a New
York Knick fans tonight to focus their
energy on christophe porzingis now it
may be proven that christophe porzingis
is right and should have left the garden
but you don't disrespect New York he
needs to be booed appropriately every
time he gets the ball boo boo more booze
all night long I know that you have
expectations because you're old enough
to remember when the Knicks were
actually good but the problem is today's
basketball player doesn't care about
that they look at ownership they look at
the instability there why would I want
to play for a franchise yeah great
building great fans maybe the best fans
in basketball but Durant said it look
they're not relevant why would anybody
one when's the last time they got
somebody who wanted to play for the
Knicks I understand that did you're
trying to hurt my feelings
you kind of break my heart I understand
I'm not gonna argue with it I understand
and we don't need Kevin Durant was so
close to signing with the New York
Knicks act like it wasn't a strong
strong consideration and now I'm cool
with Brooklyn they have a hyperbolic
chamber Kevin Kevin Durant why are you
even doing have you ever seen a guy
who's not playing the entire season who
is many seen hour long interviews than
Kevin Durant we heard from klay Thompson
we have no way because he's not playing
we won't hear from Steph Curry the rest
of the year if he has in play and if he
you know I think I never seen a guy who
has nothing to do with the season do
whole you know a little life and time
interviews they chill out do this just
go get your burger it helps I wanted to
you healthy but don't act like you
weren't considering coming to the Knicks
but but I can't argue with him I
understand what he's saying and I think
at this point you know and I'm not one
of these people who blames owners blames
owners but I'll tell you what the truth
is it is Doan and and and you know the
aesthetic of New York City they need to
bring the entire New York Knicks of
facility to Manhattan so if you are a
young millionaire you are a young star
you're not living with the soccer moms
no just don't disrespect
soccer moms out there outside of New
York City because the Knicks don't live
in New York City because the practice
facility isn't in Manhattan doling
you're such a big shot your father gave
you all these buildings get yourself a
building right there in Manhattan let
these young stars live in Manhattan at
the New York's New York City lifestyle
and that will help they all love
shopping and we are some questionable
clothing some of these young guys with
the fashion and you know Dan you wear
the tight jeans and the cool sneakers
you're one of them but but that's one of
the reasons it's Dolan and we need to
bring the entire facility to Manhattan
money-making minute were you playing
tonight what do you add helium helium
comedy club in Portland I am at the
helium comedy club in Portland Oregon I
will be there Thursday Friday and
Saturday I am I am huge in Portland and
I'm gonna say are you really yes
I'm sending my fan base there yes I we
kill it in Portland we want great I'll
be there all week and I'm looking
forward to it I love porn it's a great
city it's a great day what a great
basketball city with the Maurice Lucas
and then and then Bill Walton of course
the IDI jail Blazers no disrespect and
Dave I mean I might go there I wouldn't
go there with the jail Blazers tonight I
know I know well now it's kind of like
it's cute but back then it was it was
freaky but but but the with the 76ers
Trailblazers series is one of my
all-time favorite NBA Finals just like
the characters and the the hair and the
knee braces and the dr. J and the
Maurice Lucas down talk and squaring off
you know I mean it's just a great a
great final series I love the trail with
my behind
whether I wear a Lillard Jersey tonight
or Jerome Kersey tonight yeah a little
street cred you know don't go Bill
Walton even though I love Bill well
that's a little too obvious like a drone
kursi Jersey might be pretty cool
don't do a junior writer a junior writer
or maybe I throw on a lot Strickland
Jersey or Rasheed Wallace you know or
you know those these are good will
regret you know if the Maurice Lucas
that's one of my
Maurice Lucas one of the great power
forward goons true goon the late great
Maurice Lucas oh you know I love the
basketball culture I'm looking forward
to some good food and some good laughs
at the helium comedy cook and and I
don't know if you're going to the Knicks
game tonight then but boom boom and more
bullying that's the actor comedian
Michael Rapaport have fun in Portland
and then he's going to Sacramento next
weekend so the the tour the rest of the
year as well Michael Rapaport
comedy comm tickets available I I
appreciate it thanks for having me in a
and I'm looking forward to a great game
at the Garden tonight
thank you Michael Knight so Michael
Rapaport for more Dan Patrick show tune
in to audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
stream for free on BR live or download
the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]